moving on I want to talk about another
aspect of the vision and the PvP right
so I did a little bit of dark sun stuff
in the I guess the closed beta haven't
done any yet and since i've been playing
solo on my own obviously that's kind of
what's all that's left after you've
finished the main campaign and
apparently it's like super imbalance at
the moment it's not so much that the
fighting is imbalanced and some would
argue that the like you can argue that
the dark zone is a pvp area it's like
you don't have to but you can but what
it really is is that going rogue is
supposed like for most people that want
to go rogue is a very fun thing to do so
going rogue is that like if we shoot
another like non-hostile agent isn't
human person yes exactly and you're like
you want to either take the risk of
killing him because he has loot and
you're like I hope he has good loot or
he's just a jerk face cuz he killed your
boss she she could be yeah he or she is
a jerk face but you go rogue it's like
you lose so much experience when you die
as a rogue that it could be 30 minutes
45 minutes an hour plus of work that you
just did that it's so not worth it to go
rogue that just don't go rogue because
the risk reward is just totally scared
so that way and that essentially just
kills the whatever PvP element there is
because most people are like well I'm
not going to do that because I just lost
all this time doing it and on top of
that there's people that are starting to
play like games and shenanigans where
they try to get you to go rogue so I'll
tell you I'll tell you I'll tell you a
story last week I'm soloing the dark
zone grinding my levels and I happen to
run into three other players that are
clearly grouped up and we're kind of
clearing out an outpost or I start
shooting at it like an area and I just
see one guy he's just kind of like
serpentining right next to me near me
I'm like dude what are you doing right
and then I'm starting to think oh you
know what he's trying to do I'm pretty
sure he's trying to run in the line of
my fire and get me to go rogue and so
two friends with him yeah and so I'm
like all right that's not happening and
I run away and they chased me around for
like five minutes I'm running circles
and I'm literally looping and they're
just bullying me and I was like this is
the worst feeling ever but on this at
the same time like a day later it
actually happened where I was shooting
and then somebody just jumped or jumped
in front of me on purpose I'm purser on
purpose I go rogue they Merc me and I
lose thirty thousand experience which is
like one level when you're in the 40
plus range and that one level soloing
probably took me an hour to an hour and
a half so I lost an hour to an hour and
a half I didn't even care about losing
the money any loot I cared more about
the experience because you need to try
to hit level 50 dark zone like as
another like another requisite in the
game and game to buy other stuff and so
I was trying really hard to get there
and these jerks did it to me twice in
one got to any person lahmacun that's a
switch shot you would have seen on
screen there as well a very similar
story somebody walked into your line of
fire intentionally to make you go rogue
so they can kill you that really sucks
that's kind of a genius as well yeah how
would you how like from Yousaf sampling
how would you even like nerf that I mean
they've been they changed so much of the
dark zone during the Alpha right like
during the beta I remember they they
change the frequency by which you saw
NPCs went up the difficulty way they're
still doing stuff now they're [ __ ]
making this again yeah so I guess
they're just gonna but you're right like
how do you stop people ya doing the
exploit like you have a shoot shooting
more than one like I don't know well
there are what sucky not may not make it
worth their while yeah I don't know what
some people are doing though instead
that the people that actually enjoy
going rogue and want to have fun going
rogue is there like okay I'm gonna set
my main character aside and make an
alternate character hit and then i'll
use my alternate smurf character to
rogue and pvp people because i don't
care like I'm not afraid to lose
anything but anyone that's trying to
play endgame or like high-end content
and wants the farm and stuff like that
day will not like ever it's just a waste
of time so are you done in dark zone
until they fix this or are you know I
mean you still do the dark zone because
the way you better personal II know
because I still I still have to go in
there to get gear to get you some
materials to craft other stuff and like
I said for the most part since most
people don't go rogue you're basically
running around friendly like the whole
time everyone is just hive mine of like
oh we're just grinding we're p being
together like whatever i'm not going to
go rogue on you like most people I would
say right now seventy to eighty percent
of the population if not more or just
grinding it like you would a normal MMO
like not trying to kill each other and
then there's
like ten fifteen percent jerk guys that
want to mess with you or something that
and it's a good ratio that's not to that
it should be higher they should be able
to like that that was the kind of cool
part of what people thought the dark
zone was gonna be is that's what most
gracious yeah you can have a lot of fun
doing that and and people did but then
once they realize how much it they were
losing their whoa I'm good like I'm not
doing that again because that's too much
time wasted right there interesting
social engineering class there was like
you make it just not worth people as
well to people to do illegal activity
and they won't they won't do it and
that's the pvp in the division and
review up on gamespot right now it's
eight out of ten and it got on the site
available on a bunch of platforms except
that we you sorry it's probably coming
try for the best coming you got wii u
play heavier heavier who has your you
play experience going on this game have
you unlocked all the wii u play points i
have unlocked a lot i think level is
your you play man loka character no no
so okay so the funniest thing is going
into playing the division right Rob and
Aaron had played you know like far cry
or ritzy so they had a bunch that you
play pointed okay true yeah the crew and
they're like haired you can take those
bucks and unlock all these cool things
before the division comes out you can or
three home on skin you can note in game
stuff ringtones you get a this
weird-looking I was rocking the stud was
it the sports bow or something there's
like this kind of jerk varsity jacket
acts like a fake Nick's fingers yeah
that's correct yeah exactly there's
someone called me like I was the dad
from you know the 70s or 80s or whatever
I've learned my own Miami yeah because
all naats laces out laces out Simon
crazy time Blair Walsh wanted laces out
okay but yeah okay I take it back you
play came forward I guess I came through
after all these years sure way to get
stuff I guess I mean as long as it
doesn't really influence the game I mean
there's only a couple of things that you
can buy from that that actually going oh
that's kind of like in-game currency
let's not do too much oh so soft like
crazy it's like med kits or cosmetics
even most of the allow a lot of the
things you pick up the clothes and one
honor
just cosmetic as well as yet uncle all
right thank you both gentlemen for
coming in and talking about let division
available on your video game platform of
choice right now go check it out